and send them to the telescope operator,
and then anxiously wait for the data to come back,
praying to the weather gods.
Now I bet most of you don't have careers
that critically depend on whether or not it's cloudy last night.
Well, we weren't going to get any second chances here.
Because the weather was great, 'Oumuamua decided not to be.
Its brightness wasn't constant.
Now here we see 'Oumuamua racing between the stars.
It's centered in the middle.
The stars are trailed out because the telescope is following its motion.
It started faint and then it got brighter, fainter, brighter, and fainter again,
as sunlight is reflected off of four sides of an oblong object.
The extreme brightness change
led us to an unbelievable conclusion about its shape.
As shown in this artist's impression,
'Oumuamua is apparently very long and narrow,
with an axis ratio of about 10 to one.
Assuming it's dark, this means it's about half a mile long.
Nothing else in our solar system looks like this.
We only have a handful of objects that even have an axis ratio
bigger than five to one.
So we don't know how this forms,
but it may be part of its birth process in its home solar system.
'Oumuamua was varying in brightness every 7.34 hours,
or so we thought.
As more data started to come in from other teams,
they were reporting different numbers.
Why is it the more we learn about something,
the harder it gets to interpret?
Well, it turns out that 'Oumuamua is not rotating in a simple way.
It's wobbling like a top.
So while it is rotating around its short axis,
it's also rolling around the long axis
and nodding up and down.
This very energetic, excited motion
is almost certainly the result of it being violently tossed
out of its home solar system.
Now how we interpret the shape from its brightness
depends very critically on how it's spinning,
so now we have to rethink what it may look like,
and as shown in this beautiful painting by space artist Bill Hartmann,
we think that 'Oumuamua may be more of a flattened oval.
So let's get back to the energetics.
What is it made of?
Well, ideally we would love to have a piece of 'Oumuamua
into the laboratory, so we could study it in detail.
But since even private industry can't manage to launch
a spacecraft within a week
to something like this,
astronomers have to rely on remote observations.
So astronomers will look at how the light interacts with the surface.
Some colors may get absorbed, giving it a chemical fingerprint,
whereas other colors may not.
On the other hand, some substances may just reflect more blue
or red light efficiently.
In the case of 'Oumuamua, it reflected more red light,
making it look very much like the organic rich surface of the comet recently visited
by the Rosetta spacecraft.
But not everything that looks reddish has the same composition.
In fact, minerals that have tiny little bits of iron in the surface
can also look red,
as does the dark side of Saturn's moon Iapetus,
shown in these images from the Cassini spacecraft.
Nickel-iron meteorites, in other words, metal,
can also look red.
So while we don't know what's on the surface,
we know even less about what's on the inside.
However, we do know that it must at least be strong enough
to not fly apart as it rotates,
so it probably has a density similar to that of rocky asteroids;
perhaps even denser, like metal.
Well, at the very least, I want to show you
one of the beautiful color images that we got
from one of the ground-based telescopes.
All right, I admit, it's not all that spectacular.
(Laughter)
We just don't have the resolution.
Even Hubble Space Telescope
doesn't present a much better view.
But the importance of the Hubble data was not because of the images,
but because it extended our observations out
to two and a half months from the discovery,
meaning we get more positions along the orbit,
which will hopefully let us figure out where 'Oumuamua came from.
So what exactly is 'Oumuamua?
We firmly believe it's likely to be a leftover archaeological remnant
from the process of the birth of another planetary system,
some celestial driftwood.
Some scientists think that maybe 'Oumuamua formed
very close to a star that was much denser than our own,
and the star's tidal forces shredded planetary material
early in the solar system's history.
Still others suggest that maybe this is something that formed
during the death throes of a star,
perhaps during a supernova explosion,
as planetary material got shredded.
Whatever it is, we believe it's a natural object,
but we can't actually prove that it's not something artificial.
The color, the strange shape, the tumbling motion
could all have other explanations.
Now while we don't believe this is alien technology,
why not do the obvious experiment and search for a radio signal?
That's exactly what the Breakthrough Listen project did,
but so far, 'Oumuamua has remained completely quiet.
Now could we send a spacecraft to 'Oumuamua
and answer this question once and for all?
Yes, we do actually have the technology,
but it would be a long and expensive voyage,
and we would get there so far from the Sun
that the final approach trajectory would be very difficult.
So I think 'Oumuamua probably has many more things to teach us,
and in fact there might be more surprises in store
as scientists such as myself continue to work with the data.
More importantly, I think this visitor from afar
has really brought home the point that our solar system isn't isolated.
We're part of a much larger environment,
and in fact, we may even be surrounded by interstellar visitors
and not even know it.
This unexpected gift
has perhaps raised more questions than its provided answers,
but we were the first to say hello to a visitor from another solar system.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Jedidah Isler: Thanks, Karen.
I of course enjoyed that talk very much. Thank you.
As I recall, we found it pretty late in its journey towards us.
Will future technologies like the Large Synoptic Survey Telescope
help us detect these things sooner?
Karen Meech: Yeah. We're hoping that we'll start to see a lot of these things,
and ideally, you'd love to find one as it's approaching the Sun,
because you want to have time to do all the science,
or even more ideal,
you'd get a spacecraft ready to go,
parked somewhere in the L4 or L5 position,
somewhere near Earth,
so that when something comes by, you can chase it.
JI: Awesome, thanks so much. Let's thank Karen again.
(Applause)